can you explain how anxiety almost
ruined your writing career
it almost stopped it from starting i was
a terribly terribly anxious young person
still i'm very anxious i just actually
writing has become sort of the way i
counter anxiety it's one of the few
things that's totally within my control
and control is what helps with having
the feeling of
having something in your control is what
helps anxiety
so being able to go into a fictional
world or create a world or follow a
story in your mind
was one of the few things that would
prevent me from feeling anxious
and yet when i tried to write them down
i was always very self-critical
it always seemed more complicated than
just making it up in your head to
actually get it down on
on paper was was very difficult and
so i started wanting to write when i was
10 or 11.
and i would write outlines or plans for
things and write beginnings of things
but i wouldn't be able
to actually finish them and i could not
figure out why
the answer was anxiety the answer was
not having a process
and and it took about 10 15 years of
struggling with that and having writer's
block and
and being talented i mean i could think
of the stuff
i would write good stuff when i wrote
but i would write very very rarely and
it would be very upsetting
um and one of the things i had to teach
myself which is what i now try to teach
others
is the importance of having a reassuring
process a routine
a very mechanical way of doing the work
so that there's no anxiety involved
because it's just like if you were a
musician you would practice your
instrument
regardless of quality regardless of of
importance you just run your finger over
the keys
over and over and over again and if you
do that as a writer if you push yourself
to just write even if it's bad if you
push yourself to just
get used to the experience of stopping
and starting and starting and stopping
every day
for days and days and days eventually it
becomes so
comforting and familiar that you can
actually do the creative stuff
the creative stuff comes after the
process
a lot of this actually reminded me i
eventually ran into
stanislavski's writing about actors and
i recognize that it's the same thing i
actually think of it as method writing
because the idea of an actor having to
go out on a stage
and be able to summon up an emotion on
cue every night when it was in theater
and you had to do it every night
was a struggle that anyone would have a
problem
doing and so that stanislavski tried to
work out a process
a method by which you can create a
a very mysterious thing called emotion
on cue even if it's not yours even if
you don't feel it
and that's essentially what a writer
does there's just nobody looking
but you have to sit down at your desk
and somehow transport yourself
into a fictional world into a created
place with
people who are not you and you have to
feel these feelings and imagine this
stuff that has to come out of you
from you know not where people don't
know where creativity comes from
you know when you get it you know when
it's happening but you don't know
how it happens and you can't so what you
can know
is if i create this ritual this routine
by which i'm going to always open the
same type of notebook or i'm going to
have the same format i'm working in
and i'm going to understand the
mechanics of writing the idea of
character
and story and people taking action
and if you get all those things and you
apply them to whatever you're writing
over and over you'll eventually become
so comfortable with the process
that you'll become creative and after
many many years where i would just panic
every time i had to write now i actually
find that writing is the thing that
keeps me from panicking
about life and that i'll find myself
every day if i don't write
i get nervous but
if i do write or if i if i trust the
process
it will absolutely take away the anxiety
i can
you can't guarantee much about the arts
but i can guarantee that
practice and exposure to the process
and creating a ritual is almost always
guaranteed to make your art better
and so it sounds like that definitely
didn't come right away from you
it took years because you you were
enrolled in school and then you left
i was i was very lucky i got into yale
university
on uh there was a freak moment
when they were accepting very creative
people without great grades
um it was in the mid-1970s and the world
was
in turmoil and things were not as
stressed as they are now i guess
all i know is i was good at english but
not much else and
i applied to a bunch of schools and i
got into yale
and so i went i didn't actually even
want to go to college i just wanted to
be a writer and i thought this is just a
waste of my time but i got in
i can't not go and i went and it was
a cool experience but by the end of the
first year i was struggling with my
writing
and i blamed college i now know what i
just told you which is that i had been
struggling with my writing before
college
and i was going to struggle with it
after college but for that moment i was
like ah
if i only didn't have this college thing
i would be able to write
which is crazy because like i had you
know four classes and i didn't have that
much to do
but um i dropped out
in my the beginning of my sophomore year
and i
called my parents i actually said to
them would you take the money you're
paying college and just give it to me
to pay for an apartment so i can be a
writer and they said no
oh okay they're not insane they're
supportive but not crazy
okay and they said but you know if you
want to come home come home
so i came home and i lived in the
basement
um and i just tried to write and
all the problems i had that i blamed on
college
they were still there when college
wasn't and i was i tried
everything it would be like oh if i only
had this music to play
then i would be able to write and i
would go out and buy a record and then
oh if i only read this book
i would be prepared to write this book
and
a whole year went by like that i just
like terribly stressed and
never getting anything done and and
trying every day and feeling
terrified because i screwed up college
and now i had nothing
um and
one day i was trying to write a play
and i ended up writing the opening of a
movie version of the play
i was reading william goldman's um
scripts and and novels and william
goldman is such an
amazing and influential writer and his
style of screenwriting is so
catchy that i just thought i i can't
write this play
but i can imagine the movie version of
the play i'll write it in his style so i
wrote about six or seven pages of the
opening and it was the first thing i had
written in about a year
and it it sort of broke open the gates
um to the concept of this what i was
saying about
having a process just learning how to
understand who the characters are and
what the scene they're in is and if you
learn to think in scenes
then you just write that one scene um
so that was that i got six pages written
in a year and i said i better go back to
college because i need something to
cover the next three years while i try
and figure out how to get over this
i went back to college this is a
terribly long story
so it wasn't far from new haven and i
they they um
they took me back um with some caveats
and then i had a couple of years when i
was going to college and
trying to overcome this writing problem
which i was working towards but honestly
it wasn't until after that so we're
talking now
years and years later i'm still having a
hard time
with getting all the creativity out
and i was trying to write a novel
and i was working as an office temp i
worked as an office temp for
12 years on and off after college before
i started to make a living as a writer
and during the many years of office
tempting i was writing at different
people's desks every day i would
have a new job every day sometimes and i
would lug my writing around a little
briefcase
and i had to learn how to write in the
spaces when no one was bothering me at
temp jobs
so like someone would say go xerox
something at xerox and i'd have like
half an hour
nothing to do and that's when i could
write and
so that was like the antithesis of a
good writing space
i'm in a public office and i have a
little notebook
and i learned that if you just think
about the scene
you're in you just think about the
moment that this character is trying to
accomplish this
one thing that they are doing because
people only do one thing at a time
characters are only doing one thing at a
time
so you only need to write that one thing
and so i specifically remember there was
a scene of a character
the story was that he had sublet his
apartment to a serial killer
he was a wannabe screenwriter and he
just discovered a body in his apartment
and he goes to call the police
this is back in the 80s so it was he had
to go to the pay phone on the corner
and i had to describe what it's like to
run to a pay phone in the corner in the
rain and tell the police that you've
sublet your apartment to a serial killer
and i just tried to imagine what it was
like
for a struggling screenwriter and i had
i had at the time holes in my shoes
because they had worn through and i'd
put cardboard in them so i described
what it was like when the rainwater came
through the hole in your shoe
and what it was like to try and explain
to the police why you had sublet your
apartment to a serial killer
i had not done that part but i was in
the moment
and that's really what it's about
thinking about the scene and being
in the moment and understanding what a
character is trying to accomplish
and why there's an obstacle to that in
this case
the obstacle was shame the fact that he
was a little ashamed that he had
gotten himself into this position
and so that's it character objective
obstacle scene there's somebody who
wants something
and they're trying to do it but there's
something in their way if you have that
then you can always find that just that
little piece
then you can write and i remember
writing the scene and going wow
i did it the thing that was here is down
there and i started to learn to practice
that process the process of
thinking in scenes of understanding that
you're
not writing the whole story you're just
in
this moment with this character and that
was the beginning
of teaching myself that process
and it still took a long time but that's
that's what i
learned that's how i survived and that's
what i'm trying to tell people now
and do you think by the fact that you
had just a quick amount of time
half hour and you knew too probably
people in the office might be watching
or whatever
that you there were no excuses well i
need to organize this and dust this
before i start going
oh yeah when i was in high school and i
was like i'm going to be a writer
but i can only write if i have nothing
else to do all day
i mean even when you're a full-time
professional writer you have other
things to do all day
you never get a whole day free um
so yeah i had this irrational sense that
i had to have the right kind of music
and the right typewriter which actually
did make a difference
and um and now i was in the exact
opposite of that
i was at a different office every week
and
god knows somebody could come up to me
at any moment and ask me to do something
that i hated
and and that's when i began to recognize
that all my insistence on what i thought
was the writer's process
um was actually making it harder and
that when i started to recognize
that if you think in scenes and if you
understand what the character wants and
if
you know all of that stuff that method
acting for writers
you can you can do it anywhere anytime
which was good because i had to do it
anywhere at any time
and that's really actually a very
valuable thing for anyone who wants to
be a professional now
because most professionals are going to
be working on
shows not movies they're not going to be
writing at home and sending it in
they're going to be in a room and you've
got to be able to deal with people
coming around you and with
orders being given and things being
changed and the more that you can get a
strong process a sense that somebody
says to you
a guy's on a bus and he's got a duck in
his bag
go and you have to write a scene the
more that you can teach yourself that
skill that tool of being able to imagine
a scene
understanding that someone needs to do
something and then
getting used to the flow of just putting
something down
imagining it and grabbing it in in a
form that you can get onto a paper
that's the most valuable skill i think
if you ask any showrunner
i think they're gonna say i really want
someone that i can say
this weird thing just was demanded of us
you need to do it go
and they come back next you know an hour
with a scene
that's really valuable and that's what
office temping
taught me so everyone should go out
there and become office tabs
and would you was there like a temporary
agency that you would check in with
and they would give you an assignment
yeah it's called payson people they're
long gone but i
say um interesting it was it was sweet
there was a very small office it wasn't
one of the big ones
and um but they had they would every
week i would call in and say where am i
working this week
um and sometimes it was like thursday or
this place friday or at this place um
and sometimes it's like you're not
working this week
um but for much of 10 years that's what
i did
did anyone pressure you to or you know
did they offer you a full-time job
sometimes if you're a temp they go i
like that guy
yeah you know eventually there there was
um
at about the nine year mark
um i did actually take one of the jobs
as a full-time job the people were
lovely and they knew i was a writer and
i didn't i was like
don't if you can't handle the fact that
i'm going to be writing every free
minute
you know don't don't hire me but we
worked it out and i
so i worked for because the benefits
helped a lot
um and also actually at that time i was
trying to learn how to do diy filmmaking
and um a small eight millimeter video
had just started and i had i had gotten
some eight millimeter video equipment
and i wanted to make features on eight
millimeter radio
as uh practice just i want to make a
practice movie
um and i thought like in theater you do
a workshop you don't just
send the play out into the world you do
practice workshops
and i thought why don't we do that for
movies so
i used my office after hours i got
permission
to uh to shoot in the office i did a
whole corporate espionage drama
uh about the snack industry oh wow yeah
a lot of insider yeah
it's brutal a thrill yeah
were you riding on the subway were you
taking the subway i
was writing on stuff i wasn't writing on
the subway i was i was absorbing the
world
in so many ways sure through every
orifice
oh yeah um but but uh no i i
i tended to write either um at
desks or um at home in the morning
before like i'd wake up at like four and
right for an hour before getting ready
to go
and did anyone question you and say well
what are you doing with this note what
is this notebook that you're
oh yeah well everyone is like oh he's a
writer
yeah everyone knew that and there wasn't
a harry at the spy thing where it's like
what are you writing about us
um but there was there was a sense of
like he's not
really at the time
was called a secretary um which i was
um yeah no people understood i was
trying to get out of what i was doing
and to be something else
and that was generally looked well upon
people people didn't give me a hard time
you